it's that time you're like lowkey kind
of freaking me out I okay what did I get
myself
into
[Music]
God why do you believe that Islam is the
truth I believe in goodness so I I like
see what promotes goodness okay so like
I'm a female right so like it's
important for me that like men don't
sexualize me or objectify me so like
Lam it's so like I'm so protected right
like I'm I'm covered and I don't have to
conform to society and get certain
things done to my body that I'm never
going to be happy with because nobody's
gonna see
it hold
on just wait for the sister to come back
make sure you guys are liking this uh
this live make sure you guys are liking
um especially if you're liking this
conversation and if you like where this
is about to go it's that time
okay not not you're like lowkey kind of
freaking me out but okay whatever don't
don't be scared hold on let me no low
key like I don't know what the okay what
did I get myself into low key but it's
okay well let's go with that I like I
like your answer actually you you lean
towards Islam and you believe it's true
because it promotes goodness and you see
the fruition of its goodness so if a
religion is not professing goodness then
it would show that it is actually not
from God because God is good he would
not pro promote evil or wrongdoing would
you agree but goodness on like what
scale on the scale that you just said
like for example the protection of women
the the non objectifying women seeing
you know let's just talk about human
women as a whole do you have a Quran on
you by the way I'm going to pull up
chapter 4 and I'm going to pull up verse
34 men are the managers of the Affairs
of women for that God God has Preferred
in Bounty one of them over the other and
for that they have expended of their
property righteous women are therefore
obedient guarding the secret of God's
guarding and those you may those you
fear may be rebellious So it's talking
about how to treat your wives those who
you fear may be
rebellious admonish them banish them to
their
couches and beat
them if they then obey you look not for
any way against them God is all high all
great so this is referring
to the women like the women on o so it's
just handing women like slap them
straight a little bit but not like
literally so you think that it's okay
for a husband to slap his wife it's not
referring to husband and wife he's it is
this is literally talking about husband
and
wife
literally it says men are the the wife
yeah okay what if if she's married or if
she's not married right like if she just
Strays and she's getting on o f or
whatever like he needs to like slap her
silly so it's it's okay for a man to hit
a woman you think that's good but not
like abuse not don't don't abuse her
like you you need again I'll ask you
again is it okay is it good for a man to
beat his wife in the sense of like girl
what are you doing you're like
somebody she's paused so oh did I leave
you yeah it was something happened I
don't know what happened oh um it
literally says spank so it's telling you
like the it says beat them actually it
says the word is Strike them not spank
but it's okay we'll go there that's why
I didn't like your definition you're it
seems like you're using like the worst
word no that's that's the word in Arabic
the word in Arabic duraba mean to strike
them look I'm to pull it up yeah there's
many but in this context right like this
context we're talking about women's
rights right like this is a feminine
like we're appealing to like women yeah
so do you think that it's good do you
think that it's good for women's rights
that men are able to hit them this is
telling this is telling me like if I
like did something bizarre right it do
no it doesn't it says if you fear that
she may be rebellious so you don't even
have to do something if they fear that
you might do something or might be
disobedient they can strike you no it's
not what are you talking about fear the
men is not fearing yes it is look it
says and you can even read it in your
own translation as well right before it
talks about admonishing them it says if
you fear look and those you fear may be
rebellious so yes so you if you think
that they might be rebellious not not
that that you actually it rebellious yes
okay keep okay keep going right admonish
them banish them to their couches right
so don't sleep what does admonish them
mean like correct them it's like telling
you yeah like verbally telling you okay
and then so if they don't listen that
they don't no it doesn't say if they
don't listen these are all things that
you do it's not no no no no no no no no
it's like a why why would you just no
you have to like if she's going to
engage in something that's wrong right
like you're not going to just spank her
you're going to tell her first it
doesn't say that she's engaging in
anything wrong it says look admonish
admonish them first it doesn't say first
that's not in the
Arabic okay admonish them first and then
why do you keep doing that it doesn't
say first in the Arabic it's not telling
you to why would it tell you one is
greater than the other right so first
you're talking to her right Hab whatever
then next you're gonna not if she
doesn't listen now you're not going to
sleep with your wife you're it's like
telling you like okay refrain from like
the intercourse with her she's done a
year and then do what and and then you
have to lightly it doesn't say lightly
it doesn't say lightly don't do that
yours that's what I'm saying yours says
yours is taking the like it's the same
meaning but your words are like the most
like like it's what the Quran says it's
it's what the Quran says it's not mine
it's like no you're reading it like uh
that's what I'm saying like you maybe go
find another go find another Gan go go
find one
more no seriously you're like you're not
reading the you're right you're right
you're right you know what this Quran
this quran's corrupted let me let me
choose another one another one says
Scourge them that's tough Scourge them
do you know what to Scourge means like
that means you beat the mess out of
something all right this one says beat
them but in parenthesis which is not in
the actual text the common commentator
adds lightly this is not in the Quran
they add this do you think it's okay to
give a permission for a man to beat his
wife even lightly you think that that's
okay for women's rights so the word beat
and lightly like I don't think they go
in the same sentence together because
say before you even say lightly I've
already had a vision of like what good
I'm glad okay so I don't say you can't
say like be lightly well that's thank
you
if it applied to something simple right
like a simple discussion like almost
daily I think husbands and wives like
have simple discussions and like you're
he's gonna be like don't disobey me or
whatever but like y'all laugh it off
right like that like that can happen on
a daily Bas yeah so he can laugh it off
by by pimp slapping her huh no and that
I mean laugh it off like as in you don't
like they don't we don't take it
seriously like if my husband says let's
go get pizza and I say no let's go get
like chicken sis like and you're
thinking like I'm disobeying him so no
it's not talking about simple level like
that it's talking about like if you're
doing something like really nasty like
you're on o right it's referring to
stuff like that not simple simple things
sister you're making excuses for
something that is inexcusable and you
know it that's why it's a struggle
that's why it's a struggle look this is
what the Bible says I'm going leave you
with this this is Ephesians chapter 5
this is what the Bible says husbands
love your wives even as Christ also
loved the church and gave himself for it
that he may sanctify and cleanse it with
the washing of Water by the word so you
see so look so ought men to love their
wives as their own
bodies he that loveth his wife loves
himself for no man ever yet hated his
own flesh but nourishes and cherishes it
even as the Lord the church so just as
God loves the church meaning the
Believers the body of Christ the
churches are are people who believe just
as Christ the lord loves the church and
he gave himself for us the Bible says
the hus husbands are to do the same to
their wives that's how we're supposed to
act how God acts towards us not beating
them not striking you even lightly do
you see the difference since you're
supposed to love your H your wife just
as you love your own body would a man
beat his own self if he loves
himself would he beat himself don't try
to trap me God logic there is no beating
in this
Lam I like you a lot man okay well
anyways I'm Gonna Let You Go okay all
right bye thank you take care have a
good day someone said a woman defending
Islam is like a chicken defending KFC
[Music]
oh my God logic